a battery-operated headlamp and no
electricity for the drill Amjad elvis is
a dentist who struggles with daily power
outages in gaza he's lucky to get four
or five hours of electricity per day but
he never knows which hours he will have
it a lot of Yundi Plan B I need a plan B
whenever the power's out I use a small
LED light or this headlamp so I can at
least finish the work I've begun but if
I lose power when I'm in the middle of
surgery it's a disaster okay is
alabaster - what hey Missy the unabomb
Allah is Yamaha hey mush mush kilo see
what c'mon this set of batteries
delivers some power for internet access
and the LED light many households in
Gaza rely on this kind of makeshift
system others use diesel generators when
fuel is available still daily blackouts
in Gaza have been the norm for years
sealed off from both Israel and Egypt
and under Hamas control conditions might
worsen for Gaza as 2 million inhabitants
the Palestinian Authority in the West
Bank does not want to pay any more for
the electricity Israel delivers to Gaza
observers see it as a literal power play
it's a political crisis in which
President Mahmoud Abbas and the
Palestinian leadership supported by many
Arab countries are trying to punish
Hamas Gaza has been under Hamas control
for 10 years not a single attempt at
reconciliation with its adversary Fatah
has ever panned out always our best Arad
and youth before President Abbas travels
to the US he wants to prove to
Washington that he has the Palestinian
situation Gaza under control he wants to
show his strength do Korean meanwhile
the population is growing more
frustrated and confused because no one
knows if and when Gaza might go
completely dark a bus should have dealt
with this ten years ago when Hamas took
over that would have been better but now
it's too late he won't find a solution
Hamas has Gaza and it's pretty on you
Gaza has no drinking water it has no
electricity people are exhausted and the
economy is in shambles I don't think the
near future holds any promise for a
peaceful life like others have Ju say
even Adam these shopkeepers are well
stocked with batteries no matter what
happens but they are also not doing much
business these days many potential
customers have a lot less money to spend